طبعا التنظيم السروري نشا تقريبا عام
65 عندما قدم محمد سرور الى المملكه لكن
كان مستضعف وبدايه وكان ضعيفه لدرجه انه
كان محارب من قيادات التنظيم
جلستنا في حائل مدرس او اداري في تبع
وزاره المعارف في احدى المدارس ثم سنه في
معهد البكيريه العلميه ثم سنه في معهد
ثم اربع سنوات في معهد بريده ثم انتقل
للاحساء لمده سنتين حتى اروح على المملكه
عام 1970 طبعا كان همم وجو- فتره وجوده في
حائل وفي القصيم كان مناع القطان ايضا في
معهد عنيزه وكان محمد العبده السوري ايضا
من التنظيم العام في معهد الرس وطبعا صار
بينهم اعداء لان همم محمد سرور خالفهم
وبدا يعمل بشكل مستقل فاصبحوا يكيدون له
وهم سبب تنقلاته
وثم ابعاده فيما بعد حيث وشو به الى
الدوله محمد سرور انتقل للكويت اعمل في
مجله ال ال ال ال المجتمع
تقريبا حتى عام 76 همم من 73 الى 76 ثم
بعدها انتقل مدرس في ثانويه عبد الله
السالم في الكويت وبعد ذلك انتقل او اخرج
من الكويت وانتقل الى برمنجهام في
بريطانيا واسس مجله السنه التي كان يهاجم
فيها طبعا من ضمن ما يكتب همم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وعلمائها
وكان او ذلك في اثناء حرب همم تحرير
الكويت طبعا بعد عام 91 بدات تنظيم
السروري باكتساح القواعد سواء في المدارس
او في الجامعات او في همم يعني
اريد ان اعود الى له الامير محمد بن سلمان
لصحيفه التايم الامريكي في حديث مهم شهيره
ايضا قال بان تنظيم جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين هو الاب الشرعيه لجميع الحركات
والتنظيمات التي انتشرت في العالم لكنه
وصف اتباع السروريه بانهم الاكثر تطرفا في
الشرق الاوسط وانهم اعلى درجه من جماعات
همم الاخوان المسلمين لماذا همم طبعا
الاخوان التنظيم العام همم اكثر تلون
واكثر ثم انهم لم يعد لهم قبول بالذات في
المملكه وفي دول الخليج لم يعد لهم ذلك
الاخوان التنظيم العام السروريون لا يعني
محمد سرور كان ذكي لانه عرف التوجه الديني
والمدرسه الدينيه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه فلاعبه على هذا الوتر فخلط بين
السلفيه وما بين الفكر الاخواني بالتالي
اجتذب بالشباب اليه وشكل هذه القاعده
الكبيره المشكله في تنظيم السروري ايضا
انه من ضمن ادبياته تبني التكفير طبعا كل
حتى الاخوان بالات فكرهم ينتهي الى
التكفير لكن محمد سرور
والسروريون ااا يعني قام قام فكرهم على
تكفير الدوله
وتكفير ال ال المجتمعات طبعا صار بينهم
خلافات في هذه فيما بعد لكن هذا شيء متاصل
همم لديهم ومن هنا تاتي خطوره هذا التنظيم
واضيف الى ذلك لانه يخدع الناس بانه تنظيم
سلفي همم بحكم ما خلطه من السلفيه ومن همم
فكر الاخوان المسلمين وبالتالي قد ينطلي
على الكثير من الناس بعض الاشخاص وبعض
الرموز المنتمين لهذا التنظيم
يعني همم يخدعون به
ولذلك شكل قاعده كبيره
اكبر من قاعده جماعه الاخوان همم في داخل
المملكه اعتقد اعتقد الان ان اتباع
السروريه همم هم الاغلب في همم الكوادر
الشباب
وكوادر همم مظهرون مختلف دكتور يعني لا
السلفيون اول عفوا السروريون همم
يعني لا يختلف مظاهرهم الاخوان قد يكون
لديهم ما عنده مشكله في تغيير المظهر في
ان يتماشى مع اي مجتمع مع اي شكل لكن
السرورين لا همم اضافه الى همم نقطه اخرى
في السروري وهي التشدد في بعض المسائل
الفكريه الفقهيه وبعض الامور المجتمعيه
همم اكثر من الاخوان
فلذلك نرى المعارضات التي تمت همم حملات
الاحتساب التي همم راينا في قبل 10 سنوات
او 15 سنه همم هذه كان قوامها في الاغلب
من اتباع التنظيم السروري